on this episode I talk about pooping and
John Quincy Adams
[Music]
[Music]
this
Carrie B hi everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 188 of
the ask gary vee show India's here India
is here and the show is on fire I'm
feeling very good I'm very excited
is this my last show before the book
comes out am i doing one Monday you know
what you should bang out one Monday
because I'm gonna be all jazzed up so
we'll do one at the core Club when we're
hanging out all day Monday so I don't
even do my last right hook a big
shout-out to the vaynernation that
stepped up real nice actually what's the
ranking right now I'm Amazon stepped up
really nice I saw a lot of people say
that they bought it so I should make I'm
making assumptions here actually gonna
go down I know it's something this is
the Kindle version 365 that's weird
bunch of you one these snapchat
Instagram contest today I'll do another
one tomorrow that was a lot of fun I'm
snap storying that I'm telling to do
something on Instagram which makes it
very easy for me to engage with them I
just tagged Brittany and she's just
sending book-burning sending books like
it's her job because I guess that's
funny alright India let's do this we
went to this salon in the up let's get
into the show let's do it
yes it was a good show by the way if
you're just watching this for the first
time two years from now you should go
back and watch 187 the quality of the
anti-big you know what I've got to tell
you the vaynernation
is very smart like the comments were
like this like my energy was down I felt
it's set yesterday there was nothing too
crazy there's no funny thing I didn't
Miley Cyrus sentence they my chair but
the comments were on point like I
watched some people like best show in a
long long time they said because the
answer is wore tight sometimes when I'm
in my darkest or like lowest energy mode
I switch I probably switch like 5 to 10%
of the entertainment value too
quality value and I think a lot of those
shoes are quite good today on the other
hand I'm gonna jumpy mood let's do it
Daniel Daniel Daniel asks how the hell
did you handle content creation when
vaynermedia was only five people to
begin with easy Haniel um you know I our
is he asking for my brand or how we did
it for others well he'll at first of all
we started at seven or so when we
started we also were a community
management company for the first 18
months so we actually did no creative
India you might have even been here when
we just started doing creative which
became the mCP were you like oh my god
I'm a community manager one day I can be
a CCC yeah did I ever tell you that I've
named it ccc as an homage to the soviet
union because of the CCCP and so and so
we handled it very easily we got to
about 20 or 30 or 40 people when we
first started doing it we took very
junior people were gonna pay very little
money by the clients and what we were
producing was native content Jab Jab Jab
right hook for clients and they had no
idea what was and a big agencies that
had creatives they didn't know what it
wasn't he and they they were
disrespectful to it they're like that's
not real creative TV is not a picture on
Facebook they still say it which is the
beginning of their demise yes so we just
willed it right like people that were
kids were like I was like who knows
Photoshop me great you're a designer
let's go
it was scrappy it's what you do in the
beginning I mean all these [ __ ]
entrepreneurs that a man at you know I'm
mad
do you know how many even went skiing
this weekend how many entrepreneurs
what's skiing this weekend people that
raised money they're not making any
money and the only way they continue to
continue their business is if they raise
more money the macroeconomic climate is
getting tight China oil like people not
throwing around money the way they did
even six months ago and
right I do hate mountains that happened
on the show or somewhere else yeah do we
know what episode it's garyvee paints
mountains calm still up amazing it is
amazing
Stefan take instead of that just put it
up for a second
Fabian ass do you think using Yelp
advertising for local photographers is
worth the minimum 300 to 400 dollar a
month investment I have no idea that is
a rarity on this show but the truth is
I've been down on Yelp for a very long
time about five or six years ago maybe
even and Thank You economy I referenced
this that I thought that there would be
absolute demise in an anonymous reviews
I believe that that has happened to some
degree I think we've seen anonymous
review places struggle and and I think
that we become cynical to anonymous
reviews because we have friends that
work at anonymous review PR agencies
like literally you guys all have friends
that you know work companies and like
when your beers with them like over my
favorite company we leave negative
reviews on our competitors of our
clients it's ludicrous
and so because I thought that was a
problem I kind of never got excited
about Yelp the five years ago and I
haven't paid attention my intuition is
that Yelp probably has enough attention
now let me actually answer this actually
here we go I like bringing value 400
bucks you should do it any time you can
afford to learn and crash and burn
you should do it and not that all of you
have 400 bucks to spare because if you
did I hope you bought 20 copies of the
askgaryvee book but I would absolutely
spend 400 bucks because even if you
return nothing you have a you don't have
to ask Gary Vee you don't have to google
it up you actually lived it in real life
and so I would tell you to spend it if
you can afford it because the the
context this is one I talked about the
other day that caught a lot of people's
attention the micro lost but the macro
win this is a perfect example of it you
might have a micro loss where you spent
400 bucks and you got nothing but the
learnings that you don't have spend time
and energy figuring out Yelp
maybe greater than that ROI I think we
should write a micro macro piece yet
what do I mean about Micro losses and
and macro wins just you know how you
learn you know why learning is really
fat people you know real-life learning
it's that real life learning Stephan not
that I'm gonna memorize who the
president is and regurgitate it and get
an A
[ __ ] especially I mean I didn't have
this actually you kind of need to know
John Quincy Adams is the second
president you know I really you know
like you need to know that crap right is
it John Adams to someone and then John
Quincy later but like of course you
don't know cuz it doesn't mean anything
you know it doesn't mean anything go
ahead it's shot I mean it's Sean Adams
is a second one I think and then John
Quincy Slater yeah which is some [ __ ] in
itself just add the Quincy you didn't
you like cheated yeah John Quincy Adams
was the sixth President of the United
States in America you mrs. Thompson and
history class that was actually pretty
good clip that step on because anything
that makes you laugh that big is good
let's do it
told you under taming now he was coming
but you know what it's actually
interesting to like we were living
through the death of the value of
information like storing information in
your brain is just not valuable good by
the way look at this man's face he's not
happy he's like nobody's gonna remember
what President I was and then one day
some of the Internet's gonna come along
yeah I know I'm actually will never you
know it's funny the brain is powerful
though I will literally never forget
that John Quincy Adams is the sixth
President and do you know why cuz I've
now associated John Quincy Adams with
Mark Sanchez in my brain that's how I
remember everything
I I literally do that for everything
I literally memorize like my passport
numbers on like Sheldon Richardson
Moe Wilkerson Moe Lewis you know like I
just what I do yeah all right let's do
it
David ass I'm coming to New York for a
month in the fall purely to network
where would you go to network if you are
in New York novice do you know what I
did with this guy i retweeted this and
said vaynernation help this dude out oh
really yeah no no that's interesting
let me just make sure it's him or if
it's not somebody else yeah do this
that's so weird you know why wouldn't it
do that that's funny because you would
have normally known that well because i
retweeted him
maybe that's why yeah it's weird
well David all right you know I think
that um I think that you know you need
you could do it a lot of ways and the
way you're doing it is probably the
right ways which is one you reached out
to somebody in the market like I did I
actually want to do something funny and
say hey pass it on and some people
reached out to you
and the other thing is you just you know
use your social graph and use
information right there's a lot of
places the network that they meet up.com
is still an old-school web 2.0 site that
you can find some stuff out about and so
that's um that's the scoop nothing you
know I don't have a really great I don't
think that's a great question I think
you were you did the right thing by
asking me because I could have been in
the mood to answer it but in the way my
brain is today I don't you know I don't
use people and use information I mean
people are information now you know I'm
interested in that you know back to Yelp
I actually huh see you did it again
India one of the reasons I was down on
anonymous review sites was I was like
this social media thing's gonna happen
and I can just go to Twitter search and
put in restaurant or to put in
restaurant names New York and and use
people's opinions that are doing it
publicly so I still think people is a
great way to go and you can get down
people rabbit holes all day long right
you see somebody you know yeah somebody
on Twitter they retweet it like I did or
somebody else replies and it didn't it
people I think another cool thing is
tastemakers like the 50 best chefs in
New York or 250 or 250 coffee houses in
New York that have Twitter accounts so I
think Google
with Twitter's interesting top 50 coffee
shops in New York City search boom you
get a list this is if you really want to
come to New York for a month and network
right then you look at the list and then
you find them on Twitter and then you
ask them hey mort's coffee shop are you
a great place for networking you're
gonna get seven of them of the 50 that
reply three of them are gonna offer you
free coffee and introduce you to the
owner like life is about grabbing it if
you go on to your fence funny things
happen you know like if you take the
time to do what I just said tactically a
meet like that's inevitable inevitable
of those 50 on Twitter seven will reply
with free coffee three will do something
cool yeah I like grabbing life yeah like
you know what I mean like I really think
so much of this comes down to that like
are you on the offense or are you on the
defense right like like I'll just go to
New York and ask a couple friends and go
to one TripAdvisor saying that you know
what I mean or you can put in the work
in a world this is what Twitter is so
special it's so special please do me a
favor of vaynernation tonight for an
hour an hour it's a lot of time tweet up
25 people that you'd love to have a
conversation with maybe and don't go
Mark Cuban and Daymond John's and sucks
go with like the account for your four
favorite restaurants in your local town
and just say sallows I love your stuff
I'm telling you right now come back to
this thread on Facebook and YouTube I
will show you enormous things that
happen because of it people gonna eat
for free for weeks people gonna meet
people for weeks people gonna meet a
local entrepreneur who built a 37-year
restaurant chain that they may learn
something from you know everybody
everybody gets impractical with grabbing
life I'm gonna get Mark Cuban one of you
out of a million are gonna get Mark
Cuban for a coffee but like if you hit
up your favorite pet shop like India hit
up your our museums where you paint you
know like hit them up like I really
believe in that I really do or like if
you really are into museums like go find
a museum account and then hit up
and google this it's Google like it's
like you know Google the director of the
museum they inevitably have 412 nerd
followers and then you hit them up and
they're prompt like I'm your senator
let's have a conversation
it's go ahead up you go to Napa you can
go and like get a list off of SF
daily.com or you can get that same list
then go to Twitter tweet at the winery
and tweet at the owner and winemaker of
the winery and have a totally different
experience for no cost except the hour
of actually putting in the work the dude
the dude and listen all of you are doing
this and there's some there's some Sarah
Tiffany but the dude that DMV today
Alexander was loose key from Poland
he took it at bat and by the way tons of
you do and a lot of times I don't do it
all the time it's serendipity but today
Alexander was loose key and more so
Poland is getting a signed book coming
to his house just keep swinging you know
what I mean the math is the math like
just keep swinging I know I love it yeah
I'm super pissed that you won that
battle
that question I completely improve food
I wonder if I sarin I wonder if I'd
subconsciously forced it to produce
great content cuz I love you so much
oh just cuz it's not in your benefit
you're like okay like do you think
that's possible by the way that's a
bigger compliment than saying you won
that little micro debate I don't think
anybody waiting any debate to him let's
move on Danny hey Gary
today we'll be right in there in London
you guys have once again spent them so
here is my question the day VP is given
us big insight into how unpredictable
your day could be our craziness
how many pillars and he consistently you
do every day you make sure you and every
day that
the only thing that I can say that I
consistently do is wake up take my phone
and go poop it's truly the only 100% or
if that means I'm balanced or whatever
that means and that we are weird world
but like it's the only thing that always
happens and I like it because ironically
I like it for the weirdest reason
because I don't want to poop during the
middle of the day I'm pumped that I
don't waste and by the way I like to
poop for a long time like I don't go in
like I'm not a utilitarian pooper I'm
like 15 20 minutes like the phone really
get in it you know I work so I like I
actually don't like pooping in public at
vaynermedia yeah I mean it's just not
fun to poop with other people there it's
why I like European you know airports
because they've like really private
stalls by comparison some of the us
could really learn can you some more
private pooping places so that's the
only thing I do consistently obviously I
work out now every day but it's you know
death doesn't know that's the only that
kind of starts my night so that was a
little weird but that's the truth I
don't know what we've learned from that
probably not that much so I apologize
the end that's consistent mornings Kyle
Kyle asked what are you most worried or
nervous about for the askgaryvee book
launch
nothing Kyle it is in the bag at this
point we did our work this there's
nothing like preparation it feels
amazing
it's just the best listen I lived
through 12 years of lack of preparation
you know scary it is to come to school
when your book report is due and
everybody everybody in your class puts
it in and you didn't even do it
you don't even do it like I didn't even
do it like do you know how weird it is
when you get that scantron and you're
like alright what are we gonna do today
BC
DDD I bet you they went D crazy tonight
DD C like I lived 12 years of lack of
preparation because of school and now
I've lived you know 18 22 years of full
preparation 18 years of full preparation
at all times and so I'm not nervous
we've done what we were supposed to do
and the presale show it and and the 18
months of the content that I've been
putting out is showing it and we're at
three to four X the book sales of Jab
Jab right hook at this point so we are
cruising the matter of fact I'm turning
down all the offers now like come here
come it's over you want me to come
yep stop it's over now it's 80k cash in
my pocket that's it you're gonna get the
books I just show up like gotta take
advantage of the arbitrage question of
the day what are you most nervous about
I have seen a incline in the
vaynernation interacting with each other
I do believe that are 7 to 11 brave
souls in Facebook and YouTube that will
leave real authentic answers to this
question and I believe that is powerful
and so I'll try to take a peek at that
and that's the scoop you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering give me
this Joe Oh Andy got hyper which I'm
Annie sup guys Babson is gonna be fired
Babson Boston I'm excited about I have a
signed copy on the way cannot wait yay
sup sup sup Columbus Ohio no nope it's
not boy I love you savvy sexy Oh guys
you have to see savvy sexy social music
video review of the book it is bonkers
we're about to tape the show a lot of
times I periscope it live but today I'm
not going to shut down
[Music]